welcome to this video playing a hot
stuff that sorry I read it player who is
that
untold em chenko okay okay two games and
zero points it's not it's not good let's
see what we get here and in the Kings
Indian marker gone off
[Music]
I mean f3 is an interesting move they're
going for the pin
it's one idea of that 90 early 92 setup
[Music]
okay if I go to h4 I guess black doesn't
want to play g5 huh I mean maybe he can
do that okay it seems that he's too
annoyed by this by this pin so it puts
the knight back so maybe I can use this
for development
[Music]
so just long maybe just long castles
[Music]
don't want want him to go a three back
[Music]
interesting
very interesting position I push upon
each form
well I had to here at the time I had to
go down here it would feel much better
only three
[Music]
is he threatening 94 here yeah
guess he is not entirely sure
Knight takes Knight takes Bishop age 496
it's not quite clear to me ok I'm going
back I wanted to go every bishop age 2
anyway and he have age 4 also in the mix
so he wants to do that ok I think I have
to switch gears him have to open this up
this is the way to go playing against
the six and using my better development
here
yeah VTX bishop chinks
there's a double threat also d6 hangs at
age four Bishop h6 is threatened that
looks really good yeah you probably had
to do that and it's not something that
he wanted to do that much is clear
so maybe just improve the pressure with
9003 or cheek first a knight of three I
can also take here and go Queen III now
okay I'm not threatening to take aged
six because I'm Bishop c5 so it's just
not good but I can do here I can do this
all right coming to have three looks
like a good move if I take here how is
he capturing okay look t 6f 6 is not
hanging so it's not not that bad maybe I
can go where five it looks a tad
illogical but it's just very good age
for g5 comes don't really see how he
prevents that and don't ask about space
yeah he also probably cannot take on d5
anymore as 95 is happening
yeah that's a very good position for
white hmm yeah
h4 bishop f2 Bishop e3 g5 this kind of
thing is probably angling for some beef
i if he has to has to do something
drastic but now I'm threatening g5 first
just lasting open the edge file g5 now
I'm also able to take these six by now
the the biggest threat here is some is
to just relish this position too much
and lose on time so I'm trying to be
quick here so the should be 5 I'm just
hoping I'm not blundering some stuff
after having him yeah after he got
outplayed that badly it would be would
be quite frustrating like is completely
busted here so Queen III I'm checking of
annoyed
[Music]
I should just be material up now Queen
takes he takes a five and that's it okay
there is also no not much in terms of
swindling this position is just not
coordinated at all Queen where am I
going with the Queen I can take g6 sir
okay three are so coming I think I'm
taking here first night is this is
hanging so it should be three maybe Maya
Tiki looks looks a bit wrong actually
Time Warner check check
[Music]
I'm not joking 94 maybe I have to check
though he has no check on the back rank
rookie 1 check he has and Quincy one hmm
okay check
[Music]
going c5 next taking the night to
possible Queen c4 check check glad for
FX anti-venom pawns yeah that looked
like a good game somehow he got a really
bad position out of the opening if he
really has to play Knight bt7
I don't know any planning channel
somewhere around here very challenged me
to a video game
no thanks and so I want to look at this
game first him Knight bt7 and Champa
shop him yeah I don't know I really
didn't like the position around here it
looked it looked kind of wrong for black
but maybe it still kind of okay I'm
always unsure I always think that that
widest is in fantastic shape in such a
position but quite often it is not not
that that clear I think that this Bishop
f6 Knight g5 this this kind of thing and
probably that's probably no good and the
engine wants to do this which is kind of
interesting because it's so quick
I'm not not completely convinced though
not convinced probably I'm not meeting
him there on the edge file I like light
and like minor pieces there and yeah
okay when blacks position doesn't look
good but still okay I went here I know
he went there this this must be good now
for a white I'm probably after this F
Hoya after f4 or the engine is pretty
harsh there - to the teks and 23 yeah I
saw that but I discarded that because I
felt that I cannot take here because of
this which is true but of course I can
just continue this is maybe even better
than the game but the game was pretty
good yeah taking and now I can take
actually increase three okay on it I had
forgotten about this possibility by now
bigger but I saw that f5 is also
overwhelming it really doesn't get any
counter play it's the problem he cannot
go b5 here just it just gives away in
the house and if he takes I take with
the night and night captures is often
questionable in this kind of structure
due to some 1964 business but not with a
pawn on f5 here like it's just busted
Jim I don't think it just looks terrible
[Music]
probably it could have been won in a
quicker way the engine wants to take on
g6 with the rook
it's a funny generation +6 and what is
this it's just two points just two
points for the exchange but okay it's so
overwhelming I think I think I was was
was doing doing all right
[Music]
oops I think I was was okay check check
[Music]
yeah here I wanted to do this first and
thinking stuff like this but he's got
this track that I was happy that I saw
that this is a really awful trick to
fall into check checkmate
yeah that was my first thought but then
okay well let's go back there and just
trade that that night drive it away and
so that there is no meeting idea with
night and drew all night and Queen okay
well thanks for watching